[موسيقى]
اثنان من أكبر العقبات التي تواجه
التبني الجماعي للسيارات الكهربائية لمسافة محدودة
ونقص في محطات الشحن
مع شركة سولار موتورز تعمل شركة EV الألمانية
على حل محتمل قابل
مسيحيون جونا ، اسمي جوانا
كريستيانز ، أنا أحد مؤسسيها  والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة
سونار موتورز ، تأسست الشركة نفسها
في عام 2016 ، وفي
البداية ، كان لدينا أول حملة تمويل جماعي
، وقد مكننا ذلك من إنتاج
المزيد من النماذج الأولية لتقديم المزيد من
محركات الأقراص التجريبية واكتساب
اختراق في المحركات الشمسية هو زيادة
المكونات التقليدية لشركة Scion  - في بطارية EV
مع أكثر من 450 خلية شمسية مدمجة
في جسم Scion ، لذا فإن ما
نتحدث عنه هو أننا ندمج 456
خلية شمسية في السقف الكربوني بالكامل الذي
كان لدى Barnet حتى على الجانب الذي
تعتقد الشركة أن إضافة منفردة يمكن أن تضيف
245 كيلومترًا من  النطاق في الأسبوع ، ما
يعنيه ذلك للتنقل اليومي هو أن
لديك سيارة تحتاج لشحنها
مرة واحدة فقط شهريًا مقارنةً
بمركبة كهربائية أخرى  يجب أن تتقاضى رسومًا كل
يومين أو
أن لدى Sonar Motors بالفعل طلبات مسبقة لـ 20000 من السليل
في دفاترها وتخطط لبدء
الإنتاج الضخم للسيارة في النصف الثاني
من عام 2023 ولكن الشركة لا توقف
هناك مالكي المنتج الأكبر الثاني
أنتج بالفعل مجموعة الحافلات الشمسية
الموجودة أعلى الحافلة ، قمنا
بتركيب 1.4 كيلو واط للطاقة
الشمسية وعندما تفكر في 1500
لتر من الديزل يمكن توفيرها والتي
تصل إلى حوالي أربعة أطنان من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد
الكربون التي يمكنك توفيرها لكل  حافلة
سنويًا تقدم ابتكارات مثل محرك Scion و
Sonar شعاعًا من
أشعة الشمس في سعينا لوقف
الاحتباس الحراري
[موسيقى]